[Music starts] [Michael F. Chiang, MD]
There's never been a time in history
where we've had so much access to science and
technology as being applied to health care.
And I think one of the challenges for the
future is how to move things like biomedical
informatics and artificial intelligence and
data science into the mainstream of healthcare.
[Dina Demner-Fushman, MD, PhD]
There is no one, other than NLM,
who is specifically dedicated to
biomedical information retrieval.
We keep people focused on what really
matters for health and advancing medicine.
[Zhiyong Lu, PhD]
Our research focuses on AI and machine learning.
In the long run, what we really aim to do
is to teach computers to read and understand
scientific papers like scientists, to interpret
x-rays or retinal images like radiologists,
at a speed and at a accuracy that's
above and beyond human ability.
[Nigam H. Shah, MBBS, PhD]
Medicine has been dreaming
about having this ability to consult a
large library of patient records
to make better decisions. We've been thinking
about this as a field for 40 years.
Finally, with the support of the
National Library of Medicine,
we have established its feasibility,
its safety, and long-term viability.
[Sameer Antani, PhD]
Every clinician have seen a certain
number of patients in their clinical training
and they become very adept at that population.
Machines, on the other hand, could be
trained on data that is free of bias from
different parts of the world, from different
ethnicities, different age groups so that
there's an improved caregiving and therefore
a better expectation on treatment and care.
[Alan McMillan, PhD]
What we've started to notice is that AI can
be somewhat fragile. If it's given an unexpected
input, it can give a very unexpected output.
And so really, the whole goal of
our research is to understand how
can we investigate where AI is
fragile. How can we essentially
break it so that we can understand
how to fix it and make it stronger.
But really, it comes down to the ability
to take what is theoretical research and
apply it to health care and improve the
treatment that we can provide patients.
[Music fades to Silence]